So now that we have the app working on the simulator, it's time to put the app,
on the device.
If you do not have a device, feel free to skip this step.
Please note that you will need iOS 8 or a later version running on your phone.
This is because our code uses some APIs, like AV Audio Engine,
that are only available in iOS 8.
In the instructor notes, there is a document that will guide you
through the entire process, of putting your app on the phone.
If you have questions about this process, we are here to help.
Ask those questions on the discussion forum.
So I invite you to read through the document now,
check this box when you are done.